hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen mod
vorstellbar sondern muss mit micro
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen mode
vorstellung in minecraft und zwar ihr
seht schon im chat magic johnson von
server und was ist die magic die
modifikation ist eine modifikation die
fügt quasi so einen kompass hinzu der
euch aber auch immer den weg zurück
zeigt wo ihr ihn quasi das erste mal
aktiviert habt wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise einfach mal ins inventar
gebe gehe und oben magic ein gehörig
muss ja ich gebe einfach da wo es hin
ach das ist unter magisches garen nicht
magic jahren abgespeichert habe das auf
deutsch dann bekommt man dieses tolle
dinge etwas magisches gas können uns
aber auch holen wenn wir beispielsweise
einfach mal verschiedenste arten von
wollen nehmen wir brauchen nämlich genau
acht stücke ich nehme jetzt einfach mal
diese verschiedenen dann nehme ich mir
hier noch eine werkbank brauchen wir
dafür und noch einen kompass und dann
zeige ich euch nämlich mal eben schnell
das crafting rezept ich hab die werkbank
jetzt einfach mal hingesetzt und zwar
ist es scheißegal welche wolle ich nehme
ich kann auch theoretisch acht mal die
gleiche rolle nehmen und in die mitte
ein kompass und da bekomme ich dieses
magische garn also das ist ein ganz ganz
simples crafting rezept also man muss
sich quasi ein kompass machen und noch
ein bisschen wolle am start haben und
dann hat man dieses magische garn und
dieses magische garn macht quasi das ist
hierfür eigentlich das eigentlich schon
ganz interessant aber für netzer ist es
eigentlich viel interessanter und zwar
hört sich schon wenn ich jetzt mal
rechts ich drücke dann hat es so kurz
geblickt da läuft jetzt beispielsweise
mal los und denke so wie ich bin jetzt
in der höhle und so weiter und so fort
ich habe ganz ganz viele items bekommen
jetzt denke ich mir faktor war noch mal
ein haus wo ist der ausgang wie komm ich
raus druck sei auf dem boden und dann
geht mir hier der weg angezeigt wie ich
wieder zurückkommen und zwar sogar eine
verkürzte variante nicht unbedingt über
diese wenn diese blätter oben drüber
sondern einfach nur hier um uns hier bin
ich jetzt wieder hier und wenn ich jetzt
einfach mal wieder recht ich drücke
hörte ist es weg und wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise mal wieder so mache dann
ist es quasi jetzt alles alles blöd wenn
ich das sogar länger kenne ich das mit
länger als 3,5 sekunden hatte hörte
diese sound und jetzt ist das gelöscht
das heißt diesen weg bekomme ich jetzt
nicht wieder zurück und jetzt zeige ich
euch mal wo man das eigentlich ganz
genauer verwenden kann und zwar hoffe
ich mal dass da hinten jetzt irgendwo
eine höhle ist oder so räume hier ist
echten lebens wurde
oder ich hab bisher jetzt noch keine
höhle gesehen übrigens die modifikation
ist für die minecraft version 1.7 punkt
10 deswegen ruckelt das aufgeben bei mir
alles weil ich keine ahnung ich finde
bei 1.8 für die performance so toll
verbessert in 1 von 7.10
ihr wisst ja auf 1.8 kann die mit shader
und alle möglichen spielen und hier kann
ich nicht mal hasselhoff vanilla zocken
ohne dass irgendwann weg zu ruckeln der
tatsache irgendwie sind hier überhaupt
keine höhlen
ich weiß nicht woran das liegt aber ich
kann es euch einfach jedoch mal kurz
zeigen ich gehe hier rein ins wasser und
denke so ok hier ist mein base so einmal
gesichert und jetzt laufe ich los und
mehr ja ich hole bisschen holz christian
hof bla bla bla bla bla und dann
irgendwann jetzt macht und ich denke mir
nur so fakt wie komme ich zurück zu
meiner holt und dann drück ich einmal
zack sondern mit mir der weg angezeigt
dann sehe ich hier genau okay hier lange
nicht gelaufen hier lange okay okay hier
ist der kürzeste weg und dann laufe ich
hier lang
und hier bin ich wieder in meiner pace
jetzt kann ich dann dementsprechend auch
wieder einfach so kurz gedrückt halten
und ihr hört die spur wurde aufgelöst
und jetzt zeige ich euch das ganze mal
im netz und zwar hole ich mir dafür
jetzt eben obsidian macht mir eben
schnell ein portal und dann sehen wir
uns direkt im never wieder dran chef
wird heruntergeladen
nun da sind wir schon in den seiten von
der roten farbe und da sind wir im
netter und wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
einfach mal mein magic john am portal
aktiviere und jetzt irgendwo hin laufe
ich bin jetzt hier am ende von diesem
langen gang nicht gebuddelt habe jetzt
drücke ich einmal kurz drauf damit ihr
seht dass es auch im netz funktioniert
und jetzt habe ich hier schon diese spur
die hier gelegt wurde bling bling bling
ich laufe hier lang hier ist der
kürzeste weg anscheinend dann laufe ich
hier diese treppe runter und dann bin
ich da vorne wieder am portal
ich zeige es euch mal mit einer anderen
sache und zwar er macht jetzt hier
wieder einfach verdammt jetzt hier
werden welchen ich muss natürlich so
jetzt erst mal geduld hat jetzt der weg
gelöst aktive ich das hier wieder und
jetzt laufe ich mal beispielsweise hier
in die andere richtung an den ganzen
blöde jahren hier vorbei geht vielleicht
mal auch hier unten da hinten gehe ich
mal hin dass bin ich mir jetzt sogar
überhaupt nicht sicher wie der das ganze
macht wenn ich einfach mal geflogen bin
das wäre jetzt mal auch interessant weil
ich hasse das minecraft ruckelt einfach
in der 1.7 so eckel habe so freundlich
bin jetzt schon ihr wisst wahrscheinlich
noch das portal ist da oben
normalerweise würde ich mir
natürlich eine treppe herunter bauen
aber wenn ich jetzt mal so drücke okay
es geht gar nicht es geht nicht es geht
wirklich nicht freunde und jetzt wenn
ich hier wieder aktiviere so und jetzt
rein theoretisch hier wirklich den weg
lang laufen
dann müsste der mir hier ja hier kann er
mir das wieder anzeigen aber ihr wisst
jetzt jetzt zumindest wie haben jetzt
live getestet
wenn ich beispielsweise irgendwo runter
fliege oder irgendwo hoch fliege dann
geht es nicht weil dann sehr logisch
dann kann er keinen weg berechnet er
kann ja nicht einfach hier durch die
luft das berechnen weil ich da nicht
lange gelaufen wenn das natürlich dumm
aber dass das okay das ist interessant
dass ihr zu wissen dass ich das auf
jeden fall dass ich den weg gelaufen
sein muss gehe ich halt grad noch
wirklich das problem dass ich meine
portal hier nicht wieder finde ich habe
überhaupt kein plan wo das war weil
dieses mit dem magic john hat er jetzt
beispielsweise nicht funktioniert weil
ich ja da geflogen bin also merkt euch
nicht fliegen im creative mord aber
normalerweise ist ja auch eine
modifikation die ich euch vorgestellt
habe falls ihr beispielsweise vanilla
gerne nutzt oder eventuell auch mit dem
server mit freunden oder so eventuell
wäre es auch für minecraft leben
interessant so ein ding zu machen dass
man sich im netz nicht verlauf verläuft
obwohl es bei minecraft leben ja auch so
ist wenn man sich dann aus lobt in der
farm welt beispielsweise ist man ja
wieder zurück aber sowas ist auf jeden
fall mega interessant finde ich ist eine
coole hilfreiche sache und hier sind
extrem viele zombie pickt man sich
gerade ist es nur ein kleines video für
heute jetzt gewesen ihr hattet ihr
gestern schon zwei videos und zwar
defekt und einmal die leben folge die
waren beide kreis bearbeitet deswegen
ich bin derzeit ein bisschen an
vorproduzieren über die tage weil ich
über karneval in köln bin und dann noch
im wohnungs gucken wohnungen suchen
gruppen blabla bin deswegen würde ich
mich aber trotzdem freuen wenn ihr das
video bewerten würde das ist das einzige
video für heute ihr habt am morgen die
dann wie wir und der download der
modifikation ist und in der beschreibung
irgendwo unten drin oder so und dann
sehen wir uns bei einem nächsten video
wieder schön